is working her way through dead crops
after Cyclone 3D devastated this Farm in
Moomba in southern Mozambique
heavy flooding after the Cyclone
destroyed much of the Maize tomatoes and
cucumbers gronia
now she has to start from scratch
farming is what I do for a living we
also have to hire people to work the
land when flooding happens we lose our
crops we still have to pay the workers
and also treat the land so it's loss
after loss
experts are worried about the worsening
effects of climate change and what it
means for food production in a country
where two-thirds of the population
relies on agriculture and fishing
this is the coastal city of Bera four
years ago after Cyclone diet it was one
of the worst tropical Cyclones in the
southern hemisphere it affected millions
of people across Mozambique Malawi and
Zimbabwe
experts say this region of the Indian
Ocean has the highest average increase
in surface temperature of all tropical
oceans higher temperatures mean more
energy to supercharge weather systems
which they say are increasingly
developing into Cyclones so most
recently Cyclone Freddy was the longest
surviving tropical storm in recorded
history regaining strength six times
over many floodplains and low coastal
areas make Mozambique vulnerable to
flooding it's been concerning for two
things first they have had
that they've been bigger
and more frequent
and that's concerning because
um
we're gonna and it's not just that a lot
of times we focus on the Cyclones
because they are very end of flooding
it's very dramatic it is
um very visually shocking but we have
other impacts like droughts the drought
from the 80s and 90s killed over 100 000
people but it was every month people
dying over a long period of time it
doesn't catch the media attention so the
climate is is scary in not only in all
aspects in that floods the droughts the
um it is it's really and if we're really
struggling with what's now and this is
the beginning it's gonna get worse
in the last decade mozambique's been hit
by several high-intensity tropical
Cyclones
killing many destroying buildings and
costing the economy billions of dollars
and experts say it should prepare for
more than Mozambique